what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back to watch two
episodes of the bad batch 13 and 14. joined
by one chin Michael over here yes MJ Tesla
our Star Wars nerd who's lost like what
you've lost like 10 pounds 15 15 pounds
that's what I'm talking about man yeah seeing
yourself on the real rejects that'll realize
this episode is brought to you by search elite
well ladies and gentlemen you know what to do
leave a like please go ahead leave a like
Mandalorian next episode will be out in a
few hours I'm probably editing it right now be
sure to subscribe click the notification Bell
for a reaction to the finale don't know how I'm
gonna be able to work that out if we don't have
early access to the finale and then Mandalorian
also comes out that day and uh subscribers said
that in full length reaction with your own copy
available for super sexy Rejects at our page
restaurant page thank you to all showing
your support and join us we're going to
watch both just back to back join us on
this journey let's see what's going on
[Music]
foreign
wasn't that your nickname in Middle School Greg I
think so are we gonna sit here all day
or can we get to business let's see it
is
not until I know it's not
one of your two-bit knockoffs
smart thinking spoken like a
person who's bought a knockoff
can hurt the Fine Art of negotiation
do we have a deal
it's not blue it's like the first
wine bottle I think I've seen in
Star Wars yeah Naboo 13 ABY poison
is not typically my drink aggressive
oh she's not a pirate she's a
liberator of ancient wonders
want to kill me you'll have to do better than that
the thing from Attack of the Clones
oh so but it's not only taking the artifact now
you should have brought more
muscle than that fee she did
well look at him Rising [Applause]
cool act yeah all right fee shot first
shoes
nice yes
whatever right out of Coco yes I
am playing against myself it is
the only time this game is a challenge [Laughter]
hurry guys did they actually get treasure
did they do it wow first time for everything
Omega spends all her time with you three she
needs friends and share her genetic profile
we never had such a thing I do not see the
issue okay my parents spanked me as a child
let's hear it um Sid
she better be dying I've known Sid a long time
she's a useful Ally but not someone you want to
cross do you have a plan you're looking at
it running away you all are coming with me
oh my God these coordinates brown eyes SIDS
the villain haunting them through the Galaxy
Sid's actually an Inquisitor
I just haven't revealed it yet
it's pretty I wonder if Luke's just looks edible
it does look a little edible look at those
cute little clay houses it's like something from
Moana I've been staring at the edge of the Galaxy
that's the r Kim it's where the artifact will be
stored it holds Treasures from all over the Galaxy
wait so you actually do good things treasure can
mean many things most of the villagers on Pabu are
refugees many of the items I recover are remnants
of their cultures and that's worth preserving what
is going on a liberator of ancient wonders miss me
ship you got some competition would you bring this
time oh her and Omega are gonna be friends ship
Liana meet Omega Hunter wrecker and Tech welcome
this is like Moana he's brought any
friends here with Neva not even Sid
nope why not Sid she must really like you it's
an interesting development then it's settled
you'll join us for dinner there's no saying no
to Shep's famous feasts lots of food drink and
general merry making ships pie huh it'll be great
lead the way ship I'll catch up I like that he's
a little Stout and not like a mean cartoonish
way because I'm a fat ass this is someplace safe
oh man Tech is gonna settle down
oh what's going on [Laughter]
something awful is going to happen here this
planet's way too nice not too shabby is it
Chevy
oh [Music] Momo
they're called Munoz I wasn't far off
they've lived here since before Pabu was
inhabited [Music] Dave filoni Avatar yeah
it makes sense Pabu has been a safe haven
for those forced to flee their homes during
the war you're not worried the Empire will
show up but if they do we'll manage well
[__] them up [Music] father and ask for
a better place to raise a child you know
suggesting we all stay on Pabu permanently
I don't know this place looks awful
I still like it here a little
stability might do you all some good
nah it's going to get everyone killed Oh sushi
I love this place I wanna have my honeymoon here
what is going on with those two you have your own
boat uh-huh you want to take it out and watch the
sunset really no that sounds like a great
idea doesn't it can I go have fun have fun
that's an order Soldier good soldiers follow
orders what's with you I'm full I am never full
time to commemorate such a momentous occasion
hope you say group for dessert I love this place
how do you like pay your dues to keep this
lifestyle oh it's a communist civilization or
it's a cult get a lot of cult Vibes what you don't
see is that meat that they were eating were the
moncals [Laughter] [Music] this is the happiest
Omega has ever looked I think it's also nice that
it's an island water planet and coming from kamino
this really is surrounded by the ocean it didn't
feel like this place yeah where's all the crashing
waves and thunderstorms you and your friends can
because it's almost time to see for yourself
like them together yeah right I'm not seeing
anything just wait it'll be worth it wow
what in the Disney movie is this that
is beautiful what's wrong that rumbling
animal scurrying
Records full records it's just this
gastrointestinal problems we need to
we're never prepared to have conflict in our lives
it's no big deal happens all the time are you sure
yeah but let's head in
[Music]
uh
turns out it's a volcano everyone
all right I don't think it's over
how did you know just like
living in LA [Music] [Applause]
yeah just like Camino I believe this island
is at risk for a significant sea search we
haven't had a sea surgeon more than three
decades the early warning system would
have activated I don't like the sound of
that that the early warning system [Music]
man them just arriving no I know
think about awful luck Leon and Omega
they're on the water I'll grab our ship
and get them you four move everyone in town to
Higher Ground we gotta get the higher grounds
[Music]
use the force Omega what a terrifying
concept this is what happens in real life
during an earthquake it pulls the
water back Leanna wake up wake up
we have to keep moving no like really right
now why are they having a sea search right
now because the earthquake it pulls back and
then it pushes the phone I have a wide now
today because the bad batch arrived and the
writer said no choice but to rush it unless
there's something bigger at play here we must
use additional means to get them over the wall
we can deploy the rescue ladder they line the
top of each wall it's like Helm's Deep yeah
Batman nice get attack get it you
take those ladders I'll handle these
is like Helm's Deep exactly what it is
I'll take the stairs
yes the rickety wood that hasn't been used
in 30 years yeah that's reliable sound
this is the last one hey can I help
you oh no [Laughter] it's happening
leave her behind Omega she's slowing
you down she is important lesson
about friendship she finally finds a
friend her age and then we drown her
lever don't stop running oh I've got you Mr Frodo
whoa it's pretty scary actually oh
man it's an awful way to go over here
throw the old man up there
just like Gimli oh my God
oh no he's not gonna make
it for a ship I don't know
what I meant more if he died just
saying Circle it's all right it can
still kill the girl push her long live the king
no oh man it's a good thing to have upper
pep property was destroyed but my people are
resilient we'll band together and rebuild we
could stay and help out with things I had the
same idea if you don't mind us sticking around
for a while now be most welcome you guys made
this happen yeah literally we had 30 years with
no earthquakes you were cursed [Music] that is
On To The Next Episode immediately
immediately no time no time to ruminate
I'm sure this episode heavily ties into the
next I had so much to say about that episode
Michael please we gotta go three two one and
[Music]
okay I like that title I feel like that means
something across her Tipping Point killing set
I don't like the tone of this I love the tone
it feels a little too light-hearted for me okay
all right this is gonna be good you know I'm bad
batches like these are cinematic [__] get ready
oh [Music]
I've done clone inmates clone mates
you're the prisoners for transport
we have a schedule why is
every Imperial such a douchebag
I'm curious why they're keeping any clones alive
that are prisoners maybe
to interrogate them I guess
whoa Cloud Rebellion yes we're
under attack sir get us out of
here jump to hide in the space do it
open fire and notify come on [Music]
yeah oh you're right [Music]
I gotta break those prisoners out we need to
board and recover those prisoners before
reinforcements show up welcome back Echo
holy God [Music]
oh smart [Music]
I love these early Stormtroopers
set to stun
nicely done nicely done
erase the data banks
to gray throwback to
repellent Commando free houses
[Music]
huh God they're so great Fireball
boys let's get out of here
all the clones have is each other
that's all they ever really needed
it's a republic of friendship
did they succeed they didn't erase the data
Shake oh man what a good loyal
Soldier good on him they always
have that make it fast the reinforcements are here
we got trouble I love that Imperial March
[Music] oh man oh man oh man genius [Music]
incredible it's interesting that they were
taking the Clone somewhere I wonder if they
need their clone genetics remember they had that
like super clone assassin guy yeah I wonder if
they're doing some yeah some something
yeah so no definitely it's all tied in
I hate feeling bad for Crosshair
that's the last kind of prisoner you
want to nudge the doctor is on his way
be smart and cooperate well he will
resort to methods you will not enjoy
this guy scares me a little bit tell me how
to find clone Force 99 they'll never turn her
over they don't have a choice she is a clone
in their property help me locate your former
Squad and you will have your freedom the way
she looked at that I don't know where they are
he really doesn't know where they are no
how would he but you know how they think
how they operate have something useful to share
wrong Sinister let's see if we can
jog your memory oh mind flare begin
oh even better nice That's a
classic it's gonna get laid one
of our transport ships was attacked
departing balmora prisoners aboard
inform me when he's ready to talk I still feel
like her and Django just had a baby and that baby
sure would explain the accent
I guess that's not genetic
Coruscant
I recovered a portion of the data logs heavily
encrypted but I know someone who can crack it
I'll take care of things here
and see what else I can find out
I love you Echo I thought that was
really the dialogue that's pretty good
he can't talk if he's dead
something going on here you may secure strengths
nicely done don't make this worse Crosshair
There Is No Escape lower the Blaster oh
oh he's done okay that's surprisingly
Humane of him she's attractive
[Music] oh my God but in this
condition he still still landed
still eventually landed he just
had to Sundance get it you know
now you are so badass Crosser I love
this breaking out of the medical facility
someone's reached his Tipping Point Tipping
Point Tipping Point what if there's like a
distress code or something it
can send out to the bad batch
yes this would put them all in
the same place at the same time
you can make one phone call
no get out of there somehow
I feel like I could beat sleeping gas [Music]
willpower it's about find out next week it's my
own special Formula One I built in immunity to oh
man return to Pabu welcome to Disneyland I love it
well we rebuilt all of Papu it only took one
episode become an integral part of this community
you all have any chance you've reconsidered
staying permanently he's in love with him
more flying lessons uh-huh text got his
hands full you guys look so concerned
though when you saw the ship no way that
is awesome she has to learn sometime
yikes you playing it you're gonna cause
another sea search [Laughter] the Collision
alums haven't gone off once because
it shorted out during your last lesson
execute a sharp swing back to port with
zero Thruster pull the tick turn nice
now that is not what it is called but
I'd rather like it Oh Come to myself
[Music]
the attack turn [Music] I love it
how was that much better [Music]
they love waving in this island doing a
whole lot of it honestly you've been keeping
up as promised God Landing Zone I do not
think that is a sound oh my God I love this
put your money on shoot down Echo ship yeah
wave oh God it was so scary looking I don't oh you
look like them but no weird this place is remote
that has its advantages
preciousness people yeah wow there's they're all
like NPCs that's exactly there this is what's left
of the files are recovered from an imperial
shuttle it was transporting clone prisoners
and we need to know where and why on crosshair's
name is going to be on it oh they're gonna save
Crosshair the attack on the prisoner transport
ship is unfortunate but inconsequential governor
simply decommissioning problematic clones will
not eliminate the threat if you send them to
me I can deal with them in other ways this
guy's a pervert full briefing on your plan
Summit that sounds like a fun thing to be at I
really like him he's one of my favorite scary
Star Wars music explanation it's not a compelling
villain and not just the echo you've seen the
power you're up against you can't defeat them
it's not about that it's about fighting for
our brothers it's our family I understand why
you're doing this but when will it be enough
Hunter I decrypted the data you need to
get back to the ship oh yep not ominous
or nothing previous transfer records
recovered from the ship's logs list
other clone prisoners detained by the advanced
science Division and Crosshair is one of them
after discovering his clone number on the
transfer register I checked our old Cub plan 88.
the Seeker we are being targeted I believe
he is warning us you know or it's a trap
it's a trap like he said for us before
how do we find out we go into the Trap
I can't pay extra for that sir
ens now you'd like to reconsider my office
why suffer more all I need is the young clone
she means nothing to you they do keep
ominously cutting or they might be
increases injection level this time
I just see how long until you break
she does look like Omega yeah right
this poor guy
crosshair's done nothing wrong
all right well [__] let's talk about it let's
start off first by talking for 30 minutes about
the Pabu episode and then maybe like five
minutes on the Tipping Point episode because
let's face it the real meat and substance
was the Pabu episode you know I feel like
if you're a fan of Pabu natural disasters yeah
oh I love natural disaster big fan I do too I
have a collection any natural disaster anytime I
see the sea dissipate and then turn into a giant
wave yeah I am fulfilled on a physical yeah
level it's like the song Sail by Awolnation
that was actually what I was gonna say yeah we're
on the same page no it uh I I thought it was
the first episode was fun um I appreciate
that we got a taste of the what that there are
other possibilities out there um yeah and we'll
end right away and I and I but I feel like it was
it was nice for I mean each of them kind of found
a new sense of purpose and yeah they didn't this
idea of I mean we've seen it with other clones
you know there was the the Clone who fathered
children and and was living a relatively happy
life when he ran into wrecks during Clone Wars
um and uh and I think it's nice because I
think we we needed to see that before they
really have to make this Choice you're trying
other people the guy in the first season of
the show bad batch right that's correct yeah he
helped them uh he helped them get their their
passports or whatever the heck it was um but no I
I really um as as slow as episodes like that are
um it was nice I think it that's probably
our last reprieve uh for the season before
it gets crazy doubted I think the final episode
will just be very much Papu focused yeah or SID
focused we're setting up season three yes it
is the big well it kind of makes me wonder
God I hope Sid doesn't have a redeeming moment at
the end of the season I really hope that we just
write Sid off and pretend like it didn't happen I
know exactly what's mark my words I have a solid
prediction let's hear it that's your non-sarcastic
prediction I'm ready for it Greg okay Luke
Skywalker shows that way I got it on sarcastic
prediction here is that it's like he's he's like
not even three years ago but he'll show up still
slicing down power converters yeah uh that they're
gonna be in a bind the Clones they're gonna
need to escape after they go to this facility
and guess who's going to help out sit Sid's
gonna help get them out of a tough bind
obviously probably with the help of fee
yeah who is yeah yeah watch and if I'm wrong
I will go into the YouTube editor
and delete this out of the video
you know I really hope that's not the case
um we'll see I I feel like there's so
many just wait Michael yeah I I definitely
I am increasingly convinced that uh Omega is going
to end up captured at the end of the season and
that Crosshair will be returned to the group and
that that will be the Crux of a potential third
season yeah and uh I think wrecker will end
up losing his mind constantly thinking he's
talking with Omega but it's Crosser sad he
keeps wanting to like cuddle with crosshairs
I'm not yeah so
all jokes aside I do think it's really
interesting did not agree to that what their
throws off your game that's okay I'm I'm focused
at it I'm on it I have sincere passion about this
uh I think it's interesting that they're taking
these clones to clearly rewire them um when
we saw that clone assassin a couple episodes
back um it all makes a little bit more sense
um and uh yeah I'm I'm curious I mean it's been
really I can't imagine anyone anyone watching
this isn't also watching the Mandalorian um and
it is kind of fun to see if I want to meet that
fast yeah I want to be that one committed a bad
man I'm not really into the bad batch but or I'm
not really into the mandal form but I love it
yeah give up Amanda Lauren but stick it in with
that man yeah just grogu didn't do nothing um but
uh I I do love I I don't think it's a coincidence
that the end of bad batch ties in with you
know a premiere of a new Mandalorian episode
um and I hope that I think it will be I hope there
is some connective tissue there I mean obviously
filoni being all over the last few episodes as
indicative of that I think you're getting your
hopes extremely high for something that's not
gonna pan out all I'm saying is I feel like in
the final episode we will see Mall dueling Hondo
and and they will decapitate Sid honestly if they
killed offset at the end of this season and Omega
was captured and that was the setup of the third
season I would be super super stoked for the next
season yes how they kill off Sid sacrifice she
self-sacrifices I hope it's selfish I hope she I
hope she she chokes on one of the popcorn things
you know that they have here and why not yeah uh
no but I I like the latter episode uh obviously
um I mean I don't get me wrong I thought the first
episode of Pabu was like Pleasant I was even fine
without there being a conflict but they needed a
reason to keep them around other than yeah sure
we'll we'll live in your Utopia here and and I I
like uh I like the idea of them having that choice
and maybe the show will end with them residing
in Pabu which would be cool but the the second
episode uh was the episode 14 was definitely a lot
more interesting I do like this villain I was very
much compelled by him the first time he showed up
I thought like maybe he's a famous actor but I've
never heard of the actor who voices him and the
the Builder that they do have to it would cross
her uh coming back it's just in Crosshair while
you sparingly in this season has easily been the
most compelling to me of the main characters in
Tech Tech I was I would say is the second pick
for that I mean I think Tech exploring romances
like has been a well-deserved uh we've seen text
slowly figure out how to be a human and I feel
like that's the last big step like and if Greg
can do it surely Tech can too so love find love
oh yes I'm still learning what humor is well my
programming hasn't quite caught up there yet
that's okay uh the data in me is rendering
yeah I'm I'm super curious so one of the hard
Parts but also I think one of the my favorite
Parts about the show is that to an extent we
kind of know how it ends in in that I never
really have heard about a clone rebellion
in any kind of like major sincere way and
you've heard about it in ways but
not in a sincere way yeah no no
those guys are such jerks when they talk
now uh but I I wonder if in their failure
um maybe there is a success that does
play into something future down the line
um all we know is that by the time of rebels there
is at least three survivors of the Clone Rebellion
I think you don't hear concern yourself of
knowing how things end that's all Star Wars now
everything we watched from Star Wars we
know how it's all going to end but do we
do we as in the character from Scream
no as in like oh the question no do
we no do we as in the middle
duck in Huey Dewey and Louie
yes no but but I feel like I like reviewing
this show more than reviewing Mandalorian
me too I know because I feel there's less stakes
in when we talk the stakes are so high in this and
the reason why Greg is because this is Star Wars
I think has actually done a pretty extraordinary
job at uh without entirely retconning filling in
gaps and making things like for instance in Andor
seeing a piece of of the Death Star be created
like we see all these little pieces connect that
tell a larger story that connects to Rogue one
I mean even figuring out like all the actions
that went into blowing up the Death Star and
submitting those plans it means the whole Crux
I can't help but imagine that bad batch will
have a similar conclusion at least with the Clone
rebellion and while we know how it ends I still
love that yeah I like it too sincere to disagree
well thank you guys for watching our review
uh I hope that you have and you don't want to
talk for 20 more minutes Greg has a Mandalorian
to edit so uh no but uh what did you all think
I'm super curious where do you think this
clone rebellion's going they're gonna lose
or are they or maybe wait is there a book on
I Don't Know Jack about the Clone Rebellion
is there a book about the Clone Rebellion no I
mean it's it's subtly alluded to in in a lot of
different places that there were clones Who Rose
up against but also like maybe they all know maybe
like but actually like maybe I mean um we know
that uh the only clones that we've seen post
Empire in uh in any kind of form after like bad
batch is Boba Fett no well yeah it's technically
clone but I'm talking about like clone troopers
is an Obi-Wan Kenobi we see the homeless guy
um and then in uh Star Wars Rebels uh we see
Gregor uh Rex and um wolf and one other guy Luke
Skywalker okay that's it uh but other than that no
we really don't know the the fate of of the Clones
um and it makes you wonder I mean that would
be a good movie the fate of the Clones well I
they live short lives um well Rex is at Endor is
he yeah he is in fact if you watch this is true
this is true for those of you that don't know
this if you watch Return of the Jedi there's an
old dude with a beard and he looks just like Rex
and no this is no hear me out George Lucas no of
course he didn't plan this but Dave filoni says
that's right well when they designed what older
version of Rex looked like for Star Wars Rebels
they built the model around it and then in the
epilogue for Rebels uh sandula mentions that
Rex fought in the Battle of Endor which means
Rex could have been at Anakin's funeral same
with Ahsoka which is kind of an interesting uh
I'd love to like go back and do another special
edition of Return of the Jedi and and just pan
out a little bit after the the fourth ghost and
there's just this is just like slightly pan left
next to that tree yeah the Director
of Photography just didn't get it free
I mean honestly that would be a really smart way
to start the Ahsoka show yeah like like oh why
is this character important zupo that's why so
well I mean how but I'm saying like those guys
lived long they're old as [__] in the in that
show well they age it twice the rate of a normal
person yeah but did they yeah all of them did
everyone but Boba who ages at that's why Boba
is the age that he's at uh in uh Mandalorian but
Rex did age twice as fast did he really he did I
thought he aged normally considering the timeline
of where he's at at the final episode of rebels at
the final episode of rebels we're talking about uh
I mean it's the Battle of sometimes the timeline
gets a little confusing but it's been like what 20
30 years since uh oh you're right he does look 97
years old yeah well granted I mean Rex was around
from the original Battle of Geonosis um fact check
me on that I'm pretty sure as well yeah I mean
and you see some of those clones involved there
at the end of rebels so I I'd assume that they do
find some way to find some Haven yeah hopefully I
mean they were just responsible for that they help
out with that I just I can't help but imagine that
they did something successfully critical that
changed the course of history and the Empire
might have like written it out of the textbooks
but I'm sure we'll get to see it I think that's
what's been happening for years with Star Wars
is Empire forgot to jot down a lot and we've been
seeing a lot of it play out over the years well
you know so long as uh Disney plus continues to
Hemorrhage money and as long as those ratings
keep skyrocketing like they have skywalkering
skywalkering yeah they have been through the roof
I was trying to keep this at it short and you just
kept it going but I like talking to you I really
want to know after this I have to edit before and
a procrastinating photography so reject Nation
question for you uh what do you think happens to
the clones uh after the Clone Rebellion uh do they
succeed clearly not but what happens alternatively
do they end up using manscape yeah do they use
manscape uh honestly if you watch Rebels I would
argue that wolf definitively has the beard
trimmer because that's like yeah if you go to
um Return of the Jedi you can see there's a person
there who is manscaping himself so manscape is is
Canon to the Star Wars yeah we should answer the
patron of the day shut up wow patron of the day
pick a name on there uh Flav Flav Doran I don't
think you watched this show we usually Reserve
you for Marvel content but you have been randomly
selected by The Imperials to get a shout out here
today hey by Sir Michael the Tesla hey there flev
Dorian you have the coolest first off if you don't
watch bad batch you should because there's
no way there's not a character that also has
your name in this show I know it's a great name
it's a super super amazing name super amazing
name yeah [Music] uh actually flap is one of our
most engaged patrons he's constantly leaving very
enthusiastic strong feedback and comments always
saying like ah John I love you let me tell you why
and he's constantly being like Oh koi dude you're
the best your knowledge then you tends to leave
comments like Greg here's what I think you need to
improve about how you come across on camera yeah
um sometimes well I think I've read some
of his comments actually I know yeah dude
I totally agree you're like right on the money I
tried telling Greg all the time I am constantly
trying to find validation from flev yeah it's
a constant search and flev knows that the only
reason that I'm getting better is because I keep
casting my fish hook into the sea of Life hoping
touch us reel him out of there yeah and I'm just
not doing who needs Dory when you've got Doran
not your best not my best not your best
okay I'll just keep swimming all right
well fluffdorn thank you for being a loyal
reject um I say this from the bottom of my heart
um Greg needs your validation please
help we need you you are our only name
of my autobiography the search for validation face
resembling conflict all right okay well Flav
we're done yeah and uh F is for the feelings
no you only go for first time I did you know I
don't know who knew I didn't know that's that
is the second time I've done it the F in
your name stands for the Friendship we'll
never have because Greg will let me do the
letter no that's all all right yeah unless
you make another account you have a dragon
this video out [Laughter] that's a wrap
foreign